Oh. Hello CZsWorld.
My name is Kaneki and I will be taking over this channel for the month of October.
During this time I will be uploading every Sunday, so listen up closely, because here is what you'll be getting.
We'll start off with a web-series called True Fear,
in which CZ will be telling you about the horrors of the real world.
You'll also be getting a new short horror film entitled, Remote Threat.
Then you'll be getting another new web-series called Al Dente Creepypasta.
Which is exactly what it sounds like.
To finish up this month, I'll be releasing a brand new episode of The Wokking Dead.
So be sure to look out for that.
At the end of the month I'll be returning CZ to you.
It turns out that he was not very tasty at all.
But when you do get him back, things are going to be a little bit different.
I've done a little bargaining with CZ... And when he comes back, he'll be uploading every two weeks.
Well... I've got a lot to do this month, so I'd better get to it.
But before I leave, let me just say one more thing...
Let's Go Cubbies!